Bonjour a tous. DJI vient de mettre à jour
trois produits dont le fameux Mavic Pro
avec une nouvelle version qui s'appelle
le Mavic Pro Platinum.
Je suis Monsieur GRrr pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas ma chaîne parle de
stratégie youtube et de tous les
produits d'influence qui vous aident à
réussir sur youtube qui vous accompagnent
dans votre vie numérique et notamment
les drones
si vous voulez en savoir plus pour
réussir votre chaîne et pour
connaître l'actualité ces produits
vous invite à vous abonner à ma
chaîne comme ça vous ne manquerez
aucune publication. DJI c'est
probablement la boîte qui a
démocratisé les drones pour le grand
public avec le Phantom 3, le Phantom 4,
le Mavic, le Spark et plein d'autres
produits catalogue. Ca permet au grand
public d'avoir de nombreux produits pour
réussir leurs vidéos alors si vous
êtes créateur de contenu vous connaissez
forcément les drones de DJI
ils ont une renommée, ils sont vraiment
super, facile à prendre en main à
piloter et on peut faire des vidéos
d'une qualité exceptionnelle. D'ailleurs
tout de suite je suis en train de filmer avec un
produit de DJI c'est l'Osmo +
je vous invite d'ailleurs allez le
découvrir ici. Un excellent produit
qui permet de faire bonne vidéo et sur
lequel voyez on peut se voir en fonction
monitoring. On peut faire pleins de choses. Enfin c'est
vraiment un truc qui est vraiment
topissime. Et justement DJI vient de
sortir une nouvelle version de son Mavic pro :
le Mavic Pro Platinum. Il y a ce Mavic
pro Platinum qui vient de sortir.
Il y a aussi une nouvelle version du
Phantom 4 Pro : le Phantom 4 Pro Obsidian
et un nouveau mode de pilotage pour le
Spark mais on en parlera un peu plus
tard. J'ai pu rencontrer l'équipe de DJI
à Berlin lorsque je suis allé à l'IFA.
J'ai vu voler les drones et je peux
vous assurer qu'ils sont vraiment
exceptionnels. Vous allez vous faire
une idée par vous même. C'est le Mavic
Pro Platinum qu'on a sorti à l'IFA
il y a trois jours.
L'avantage du Mavic Pro Platinum par
rapport à la version originale c'est que en fait
comme vous l'entendez il est très
silencieux avec 60 % d'émissions
sonores en moins.
Et un temps de vol aussi amélioré
de 11% qui le portent
aujourd'hui à 30 minutes vol
contre 27 minutes pour la version originale
Vous avez changé la batterie ?
On n'a pas changé la batterie, en fait on a
travaillé, on a amélioré le
le contrôleur de vitesse électronique.
D'accord.
Et les hélices aussi qu'ils
ont été modifiées, l'aérodynamisme
des hélices aussi.
Donc les deux font que on ne l'entend presque plus et c'est super.
C'est vrai que c'est discret.
C'est beaucoup plus appréciable.
Ce produit là, le Mavic Pro est un peu
plus cher que l'ancienne version
j'imagine ?
Il est un peu plus cher il est
à 100 euros de plus.
On le retrouve à 1299 euros et la
version originale et 1199 euros.
Vous pouvez le commander aujourd'hui.
Il est disponible
aujourd'hui à la commande et
livrable à partir du mois de septembre.
Dites-moi ce que vous en pensez.
Dites-moi quel drone vous utilisez si
vous envisagez d'en prendre en l'avenir ?
Oui ? Non ? Si oui lequel ?
Un DJI ? Une autre marque ? Vous me parlez de tout
ça en commentaire et moi je me ferai un
plaisir de discuter avec vous. Je vous
invite à vous abonner à ma chaîne
pour en savoir toujours plus sur votre
stratégie Youtube et pour découvrir
tous les produits qu'il vous faut pour
réussir et les produits d'influence.
Les produits les plus sympas du moment. Si vous
avez des questions vous pouvez me
rejoindre sur twitter @MonsieurGRrr et
avec le #ASKMonsieurGRrr
Quant à moi je vous remercie d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo je vous dis à
très bientôt pour nouvelle vidéo
d'ici là portez vous bien
salut